il ya très longtemps que j'avais
l'accord que j'ai la conviction que
notre civilisation court à sa perte
1971 l'avenir de la civilisation
industrielle était le sujet de cette
émission présentée par michel colla et
certaines prédictions n'était pas très
optimiste
je ne crois pas la disparition de
l'homme sur la tête ce que je crois
c'est la disparition de l'homme
technique à terre parce que l'homme
technique détruit la nature
on empoisonne l'atmosphère empoisonnée
des catastrophes climatiques mais aussi
économique responsable de l'effondrement
de la civilisation industrielle
une théorie appelée aujourd'hui la colle
absolue et qui émergent en france au
début des années 70 à cette époque la
société de consommation est à son apogée
la crise pétrolière se dessine et
l'épuisement des ressources commence à
un clip c'est ce cet équilibre entre
populations production ressources
espaces disponibles qu'il faut trouver
de trouver assez rapidement sinon si
nous ne faisons pas ça nos fils nos noms
les prochaines générations devront payer
notre égoïsme aurelio pesci et le
fondateur du club de rome un groupe de
réflexion international réunissant
scientifiques économistes hauts
fonctionnaires et industriels tous
préoccupés par l'avenir de nos
civilisations en 1972 avec l'aide de
chercheurs américains
il publiait le rapport meadows un
document scientifique précurseur qui
alertait sur les dangers de la
croissance cette étude a mis en relief
les tendances les plus inquiétants de
notre développement et leurs
interactions
la plupart de ces tendances sont d'ordre
exponentielle disent les auteurs du
rapport
autre point inquiétant pour les auteurs
du rapport la croissance démographique
planétaire il préconisait même une
régulation des naissances
il faut construire un deuxième monde
seconde monde pour abriter les nouvelles
vagues de population c'est un travail de
construction un gala ce que l'humanité a
fait depuis le moyen-âge le rapport
meadows prévoyait l'effondrement de la
civilisation industrielle pour 2030 dans
une dizaine d'années donc aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de collabo log le voit
venir beaucoup plus tôt
[Musique]